here's something folks my next guest
says that Americans had to become Market
speculators because this is what happens
as the US dollar continues to lose value
joining me now pop Investments investor
Anthony Pano uh Anthony you included a
chart in this as well to sort of
illustrate uh you know some of the
things that are happening here we have
the US listed companies this is another
Factor right going from over 8,000 to
just a little bit more than 4,000 the
whole thing seems to be conspired to
funnel us make us funnel our money into
these markets otherwise I mean how do
you keep up with anything I don't know
if it's a conspiracy I I don't know if
people are that smart but definitely
what's happened is there's a structural
issue in America if you look at the debt
I mean just in the early 2000s we were
still running a surplus in this country
now we're running multi- trillion dollar
debts the total National debts over $33
trillion and so if you have this
overhang of debt you've got to go and
you got to devalue the currency so as
they've done that we've seen this income
inequality drastically explode and so
now you have 50% of Americans that are
winning who are holding stocks 50% of
americ Americans that are not holding
stocks are losing and so what we've seen
is since about late 18 or 1980s uh and
1990 till today we went from 30% of us
households that held stocks to almost
60% so we've doubled in the last coup
you know 30 something years and so what
that tells you is that people are waking
up they're realizing if I simply hold
savings it is going to get devalued away
I have to go into the market and so
doubling from 30% to 60% of us
households now hold uh US stocks and so
all that tells you is that people are
getting smarter Television Internet Etc
educating them and I think that it's
only going to continue so here's the
thing that I do find interesting though
with that the whole notion like you know
okay have this much debt because CH
Japan was ahead of us right and I
remember when everyone thought Japan was
going to be the number one economy in
the world you know that was back in the
day they were they were buying
everything up uh and all of a sudden
they've imploded and they've never
really been able to get back their their
footing it seems like okay maybe this is
a good deal for investors but for the
nation if it feels like we can't go back
uh no one has the willpower in Congress
to go back to say I'm going to cut
spending so it feels like the nation's
fate could be sort of sealed I don't
know what would replace us maybe that's
the only thing saving us right now well
we definitely we control the global
Reserve currency so that's a huge you
know benefit and and kind of Tailwind
for us but I don't see us balancing a
budget anytime soon I don't see us
paying back the debt anytime soon um and
so definitely it looks like America's
future is going to be based on taking on
more and more debt now what that means
is as an individual whether you like it
or not you can't change that right there
there's no one individual is going to be
able to change politics or Congress or
any of that stuff so what you have to
start thinking about is with your
portfolio what are you going to do and
what we've seen is that again inflation
and debt equals returns and stocks uh
you know bonds Commodities Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies Etc and so I think
you're going to have an entire
generation of people who are growing up
in a more financialized world and
they're going to plow all of this
Capital into financial markets speaking
of what you say that we're right now on
the cus of the biggest marketing Blitz
in financial Market history and a lot of
that's revolving around Bitcoin think
about 50 billion dollars or so coming
into these ETFs that are going to get
approved at some point here in the
future uh if you look at the fee uh
schedule that's somewhere between 500
million and a billion dollars of annual
revenue that's up for grabs and it's not
just for one year that's every single
year for perpetuity right how much would
you spend if I said that there was $500
million that was up for grabs 100
million 200 million 300 million I don't
know what the answer is but we're about
to find out what these firms are going
to do I'm digging in one with the most
interesting man in the world bitwise
that's a good one yeah that's a great
one it's going to be hard to one to one
up on I mean I think that's a really
good one listen when you put Black Rock
Fidelity bitwise and many other of these
issuers together not only you're going
to have a lot of money spent you're
going to have a lot of creativity come
into the market and so what we're really
GNA watch here is in some way Wall
Street is about to go and Market Bitcoin
and cryptocurrencies to the nation and
that's only going to lead to more
capital I got less than a minute to go
maybe 30 seconds but I was always a
little Larry I know on one hand
obviously these names they control
everything right they they there are the
Titans of the world but on the other
hand I always feel like when they get
involved something goes wrong for the a
average investor out there maybe Bitcoin
doesn't get derailed but are you know
are you comfortable now with these big
big names coming into this space I I
think it's just inevitable if you want
Mass adoption well you're going to have
to get these large organizations to go
ahead and adopt it and as that occurs
you just have to remember there's a
trade-off and so yes there will be some
blunting of some of the other aspects of
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies and we can't
change it so just be prepared get
educated make sure that you understand
what the market structure is going to be
over the next coming years I love your
attitude listen you can't change it so
make the most of it in this case make
some money
pop have a great Christmas thank you so
much for having all right